now it is an epidemic you probably heard
about maybe even one you've fallen
victim to we're talking about the theft
of catalytic converters all across our
valley they are pieces of your car that
thieves want to get their hands on and
tonight the eight news now i-team
exposing what's making these cases
really difficult to solve the i-team's
david charns with a simple solution that
could help police and stop the stealing
[Music]
mechanics at universal motor cars see a
lot of vehicles most of them i saw
without calorie converters victor
bottnari is showing us a car with its
catalytic converter it's cleaning the
exhaust the metal tubes don't look like
anything special but inside they're
packed with precious metals that makes
them a target for thieves it's a
phenomenon right now that phenomenon an
explosion of catalytic converter thefts
right from under our noses or in this
case under our cars thieves cutting them
out in a matter of seconds lieutenant
joe lapore is with metro police how are
these people making money from what
they're stealing one way is through
scrap yards there's also a big black
market metro police say they responded
to more than 1900 catalytic converter
calls last year each call could be for
one converter or several 98 of those
calls are closed that's 5 percent where
there's an arrest or citation the big
problem seems to be that the catalytic
converters can't be identified right
correct
and that's one thing that does hamstring
us quite a bit the parts themselves have
no identifier no way to tie them back to
their home vehicle and most importantly
its owner it makes it much more
difficult to prove that case police say
the red flags are repeat offenders or
someone who comes in trying to pawn off
more than one at a time
it's a thursday afternoon in las vegas
we're following along as i-team
photojournalist matt adams is attempting
to sell an after market catalytic
converter from a junk car
his first scrap yard turned him away
they don't accept them anymore but on
his second try we learned selling one
sometimes isn't so easy
our sale goes by the book
our photojournalist had to show his id
even get fingerprinted it will be your
right index finger all for 22.50
that's it
this shop going above and beyond what's
required there's no law on the books
right now that prevents this however
there are scrap yards that do work with
us
and will report to us if they get people
that come in constantly to bring in
catalytic converters the i-team asked
some of the most popular car companies
if they would consider adding
identifiers to catalytic converters on
the cars they make a spokesperson for
toyota said new laws are the answer at
quote eliminating the market for these
stolen parts a honda spokesperson said
they strive to enhance their vehicles
including security how much is on the
scrap yards
for
buying them but that's just an internal
policy that's nothing
there's no law to stop that right now
this business doing everything police
could wish for but there is no mandatory
reporting in clark county or nevada that
would be a game changer for our
investigations because we would able we
would be able to tie that specific
catalytic converter to a specific report
to a specific victim
back at the shop that's something
botnari says is a no-brainer if there
are serial numbers that will match with
the view number probably way easier to
find well no car company we heard from
said it would consider adding an
identifier the alliance for automotive
innovation told us it is working with
policy makers and police to increase
awareness and deter this criminal
activity several states are passing laws
to curb these thefts by requiring paper
trails or banning cash transactions
among other measures i'm david charns
live local now